when they're not afraid of losing
everything people lead better founders
are okay because founders realize I have
to figure out whether we can pull this
off or not I'm willing to start off you
know start from scratch against that
that level of you know determination of
getting it and realized that I may have
to start all over again gets respect
from competitors gets respect from
talent gets respect from their employees
gets respect from their customers gets
respect from their vendors because they
say wow this guy's really willing to
push the envelope and he's pretty
determined he's certain what he's doing
something's different about this guy the
only way a great founder is gonna be
able to build a big big company is at
some point you have to be willing to at
this breaking point where it's either
sink or swim they are not afraid of
getting to this point a lot of people
are afraid they play way too safe these
guys are now I'm willing to get to it's
okay
horse kissing I'm gonna die I'm okay
with that but I'm gonna fight like hell
to make sure we make that and make it
out of this you know issue that we're
facing right now